[Music]
everyone has an angel very sure a crappy
cover version of a good song on the
soundtrack get used to it because it
happens with you feeling meow in your
head on the ground with every single
[Music]
Disgaea shakes his head no and we're
supposed to know what that means no you
didn't win Miss America no you don't
have herpes
no you're not being paid for this Phil
whatever it is he's saying no to she
runs into the other room in a panic
which helps me the viewer understand
exactly diddly squat reveal of the dead
mother just in case the viewer assumes
that it was their dog that died or
something training at a funeral where
all the umbrellas are black cliche it's
convenient that the text that is
important to this montage happened to
type bolder than the rest of this text
there was a lot of implied character
development going on right now um this
is the same angry lawyer who just got
pissed about some dead guys will write
and his immediate thought is to go rape
some boardinghouse girl and this
specific girl then he changes his mind I
guess and turns to go rape someone else
but then shows he also has the key to
this girl's room
he went from lawyer to slave owning
dungeon master in like ten seconds look
movie at this point I'm gonna have to
refuse to care about anything I see on
screen until it's lightly remotely makes
a modicum of sense
no she's hanging from a thing and that
one guy is kicking something and yet I
feel nothing where did she get the gun I
already don't care this girl is a storm
trooper level terrible shot she is five
feet away from a pretty large man and
still misses so did the bullet ricochet
off the white ball then off the steam
pipe and then into the sisters head was
in her continued pursuit to make
terrible decisions she throws the gun on
the floor getting her potential to
saying like the option to pick it up and
shoot her if he pleases
apparently that shot they gave her
sedated her and fixed her mascara I have
no idea what's happening or what stories
either of these individuals told police
but somehow they can let her go in the
custody of that guy that attacked her
irregular rain patterns on a car window
turned into movies title and that's
actually the most sensible thing I've
seen so far I'm not sending something I
have no idea if this was once a custom
but I'm sending this house for having
the name of the house and the city and
state on the sign like a goddamn
expositional warning beacon I've been
watching this movie for five straight
minutes and I have no earthly idea why
she's being committed does that say more
about me or the movie also you can kind
of make out the faint pink before
clothing otherwise it's black and white
which is par for the course on his axe
nighter film
mute the colors mute the characters meet
at the story until your sign tells the
whole story while exterior sign makes no
mention at the facility's mission email
28:20 why didn't she just run away with
her sister after her mother died oh man
they drive for pre fam Oscar Isaac into
this didn't they so this is what we call
the fear and when I call obnoxiously
breaking the fourth wall ponies
that's racist now damn carla Gugino is
there any comic graphic novel adaptation
you won't star in Watchmen Sin City this
what's how you say this isn't an
adaptation of a comic Zack Snyder
actually wrote this movie Wow
but kind of explains things told police
she lost her mind when her mother dies
truth is a little more complicated well
he tried to rape her and her little
sister then she tried to shoot him but
killed her sister
I guess that qualifies as a little more
complicated don't worry she won't even
remember her name when I'm done with him
but until you're actually done with her
is this a smart thing to say what's
going on no seriously what's going on
why not tell the therapist about the
head orderlies plan to lobotomize you
because your rapist stepfather paid him
off there's actual proof the forged
signature I'm getting a strong feeling
that this movie is going to be mostly
slow-motion montages also most of the
budget clearly went to CGI but the other
thing they spent a lot of money on was
eyeshadow if only and suddenly you
learned this is on a stage play which
does nothing to reduce my own viewers
WTF Peter that's a question that
basically never needs answering as the
answer is likely to include abandonment
suicide and other horrors orphan
children are better off not thinking
about clients discount bunnyranch
she stuck up to me why does the brothel
have a ballet practice room
and why are so many of the prostitutes
here into ballet but he gets a dance
routine they practice it practice it
practice it in the men come and watch us
perform they like what they see this is
a needlessly complicated way to run a
whorehouse
that's they're a rival whorehouse across
town where the girls are all really
talented artists and whoever's painting
the client likes bestest the one he
chooses of course that's not a rival
whorehouse this is a fantasy world that
takes place he to play how doesn't this
girl know that spending your first night
in prison crying is bad did she not see
Shawshank
and if prostituting wasn't enough she
has to clean the floor like King Little
Orphan Annie
what kind of brothel is this I realize
she's having some kind of vision right
now but um they stopped her last time
for not dancing by this point the song
and here she is again not dancing by
this point the song I'm just saying
sometimes I got more lenient your shoes
you're tracking snow everywhere um no
she is these are your weapons okay cool
but what is a map and Fire
and a key the fifth thing is a mystery
sounds like someone forgot what the
fifth thing was this girl goes from
captive to warrior in like unbelievable
record time yo
she survives this or gets kicked back a
little I don't know what the rules are
after getting flung around by a creature
that clearly has the upper hand her
swords suddenly surging with stopping
power it's nice of them to come in one
at a time instead of all at once monster
number two's name is almost as terrible
as hers
supposed to be monster number two his
first day with that machine gun clearly
had no idea how to use it since she was
basically able to run up to him and
shoot him without any trouble well if I
had a little white flag I would be
waving it in this movie's general
direction I'm beyond loss times two when
the hell did she get these neo powers
monster number three didn't even put up
a fight you probably couldn't see
through that lampshade he was wearing
and now we're back to dance practice
making the previous eight minutes of
fight scenes mostly moot yay I hope
you're not too interested in this
mind-blowing dance babydoll performs
because we never can see it also did her
dance include her being confused and
talking to white sensei about her
weapons and the things she has to
collect I feel like that part would
still be mostly standing don't want to
hear you plan okay none of us do except
the obvious two or more that clearly
won't to hear the plan what does this
even supposed to mean it's a good plan
what kind of question is this
will Sweet Pea respond with well yeah
I'll hear it if it's a good plan the
girls in this Guantanamo brothel have
showgirls style makeup tables for some
reason safe through a lot of sweet B
seems to forget their sex slaves she had
a knife to his throat yeah but then she
gave the knife back by dropping it right
in front of it here are all the things
we'll need to escape
I'll write them really big right here in
the public room how do you getting these
things good question we need I got them
to watch me dance last time you danced
all I saw was some weird-ass bull olden
times samurai battle in the snow so what
did they see different that will make
them sign up for the cause as long as
I'm dancing god damn this girl is
looking high on her own seductiveness
second thing we need is something to
start a fire with as a distraction from
we escape because fire is the only
distraction people will believe what is
it my thing
it's master key well how do you know
that the third thing is a knife you had
a knife but you can drop it this plan is
crazy this trick would be excellent at
cinemasins okay can you wait to cross it
off until you get it have you ever seen
a list before if the girls just get
their own free weed think that blue
would lock the door to his office but
then you might remember that this is
just baby the host a dream I guess baby
doll has only been exposed to terrible
things because she seems incapable of
dreaming up anything a normal
well-adjusted person would dream up
someone please
Blayne Hawaii - this girl no one
involved in the production of this movie
said anything about dick blimps they're
using steam power and clockworks to keep
him moving uh complaining about the
absurdity of this film's fight scenes
would be like complaining about wily
coyote surviving his run-ins with
malfunctioning Acme products but I'm
gonna do it anyway because the fight
scenes are worse than absurd boring here
a handgun will take down a fighter plane
because why not this is some pretty
advanced technology for what looks like
dystopian steampunk world war 1 baby
dolls reality only gets us to the
fifties issue so she would have no way
of imagining anything like this and now
Vanessa Hudgens is kicking ass with kung
fu engine and I'm absolutely tuning out
from here on I mean goddamn she's a
recently enslaved ballet prostitute
right not the she know - glamour flash
her weapons and no standard military
hand signals huh not really
she's just imagining all this he's not
some monster pond zombie barrack
literally looking the fuck out she fires
at him several times but somehow even
while missing him she still misses the
giant balloon airship definitely still
watching fantasies here and not reality
everyone's still back at the ladies sex
prison this is all a really expensive
dream also here's another movie that
somehow feels compelled to remind me of
sky captain in the world of tomorrow
every time a Zeppelin burns a rubber
plant gets its wings stop dropping
useful weapons now she's deflecting
bullets with a sword
Jesus exactly how Jackie Chan wants you
before the imprisonment she's probably
wishing she had a machine gun right now
Wow Jamie Chung Pacific Rim gear just at
the perfect moment my real question is
how did blondie know that was gonna
happen because if it doesn't happen
blondie is dead no yep you just watch 12
minutes of absolute bullshit
also from what I can figure these girls
aren't prostitutes but are instead
dancers and men pay big money to see
them dance in a rehearsal space but
every time they dance we the audience
see some kind of battle that isn't
actually real do I have all that right
because if so this movie all she has to
do is do what she did just now okay
that's fine but just don't make me watch
that fight scene to get away from my
sweet be followed
Runaways often end up in prostitution
but this isn't prostitution remember
this is a fantasy in babydolls head
right before she gets a lobotomy so did
these two sisters run away and end up in
a mental institution or did baby oil
make it all up
you just haven't wanted to just take
something back you know something you
said something you did yep the no
gravity and space wording on that sin
from the Avengers video oh wait you
weren't talking to me directly were you
the imprisoned dancing prostitutes
apparently have to clock in kiss
thank you like that what neck approach
skip oh yeah and one more thing don't
wait a month no seriously skip so this
plane only has one propeller yet it's
still allowed to fly normally I can't
fault baby don't for not knowing how
planes work wait yes I can't you know it
would at least be nice of the movie to
sort of try to barely sort of explain
why the dances always show up as battle
scenes right I mean is the entire movie
an example of the imagery sex slaves are
forced to conjure up during forced sex
sessions because if so why would you
make a movie about that I guess Tolkien
and Peter Jackson didn't lock down the
copyright on works so everybody gets to
put them in their movie if they want yep
it just shot an orc in a catapult and he
actually landed on the plane they were
aiming at that just happened these
creatures decide to launch two of their
soldiers at the plane instead of a giant
rock or an explosive literally anything
else that might be more effective the
Dragon Nest is human bones which is
basically garbage it's like if I slept
on a pile of takeout boxes now I get
back to Egypt and activate Lulu dragon
helm scream she doesn't say fuck so we
can maintain the pg-13 rating all while
exposing thirteen-year-olds to the idea
of the word you complete doubt all you
want but everyone knows what you're
fucking saying and anyone who does that
is ridiculous that dance routine about
killing a dragon brought this asshole to
genuine tears why who cares you know you
just have a lighter you're still in the
same fucking place I'm worried for these
girls when they finally do escape into
the real world and find it's not all
hallucinatory battles but whatever hot
girl hug the fraternity of performance
technically this would be a sorority
I need this bull to stop but what they
dance the fat man with the cigar loved
it in clamp where is the bull we need a
music pitch perfect lines spoken to Anna
Kendrick somehow works its way into this
script which is understandable
considering how much weird-ass boy and
I've already seen potatoes everything up
until now has told me that when these
girls dance we see battlefield but this
time we just watch our awkwardly danced
on commercial kitchen equipment and now
for no reason here's Saturn in the
background because this is suddenly
taking place in either space or another
dimension where Saturn is this fucking
huge and visible from Earth look they're
still physically back in the ballet room
doing a sexy dance right now right I
mean this movie tells me nothing about
what's real and what's fantasy all these
extra robot warriors keep coming from
she's gone twice around at least at this
point but robots keep Atty realizing
like it's a movie or something oh no
they have to deal with this bomb before
it blows up the city that doesn't exist
if her dancing is what puts people in a
trance then why is the absence of music
a problem unless it's actually the music
that in snares fat man just keep dancing
Jena Malone dies but she was saved in an
earlier movie so I'm not that worried
about her soul
did they really need to drag Don Draper
into this it's the rampant murdering
without consequence supposed to be a
metaphor for lobotomies or did the
mental hospital actually kill them
except for all those other girls who are
also sex slaves but we don't care about
them apparently she stabbed the main
dude but didn't bring that knife or
steal any guns and before this big
breakout make sense movie that is either
about risk a ballet recitals or violent
battles somehow ends up in Bruce Wayne's
driveway I said where you going why even
do this
I thought she had sexy hypnotizing dance
powers that could have distracted this
group of goons for hours just one week
here she stabbed and orderly started a
fire and and helped another patient to
escape and she made it all seem very
cinematic and worth watching and
stretched it out over two hours and for
some reason included harmless ballet
classes which you wanted me to do it
hot tip in a movie that features a lot
of rape don't have a character say the
sentence okay well I feel like the guy
who showed up so late to the party he's
the only guy not understanding the three
hour old inside joke shrink patient
prisoner ninja why does the movie you
think I give it anymore came out they
took her away too late though she's
already corrupted and the rest of us
well we're already scarred enough as it
is and confused but mostly confused I
know it's okay
go find a seat in the back try and get
some sleep
congratulations mr. Imaginary guardian
angel but also maybe a real guy for
being the only man in this entire movie
who is not a rapist
I'm gonna terrible dance floor ever
since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes
[Music]
[Applause]
then born again my whole life accepting
Jesus into your heart and getting saved
is a big decision it's the hard-knock
life you can prevent forest fires only
you
attention attention personnel
no casualties expected for indefinite
period I really gonna try to escape
don't even think about trying to escape
[Music]
the last one